فهل كانوا يستهدفون الصحفيين كانوا
بالتاكيد يصوبون باتجاه الصحفيين
بحسب مصادر خاصه فان مسؤولا اسرائيليا
كبيرا في مكتب وزير الدفاع الاسرائيلي
السابق بني جانس اعترف لمسؤولين امريكيين
بان شيرين قتلت بنيران اطلقها الجنود
الاسرائيليون خطا لكن اسرائيل لن تعلن ولن
تعترف رسميا بذلك
[موسيقى]
لاحظت ان هناك مجموعه من الصحفيين كانوا
يسيرون في الشارع
كان في هذا الشارع جدران ومنازل ايضا
وكان ذلك بمثابه تقييد لمسار الرصاص
عندما بدا اطلاق النار
وكونت الطلقه صدمه
انفجار الطلقه
كان هناك فارق زمني من هذا الفارق الزمني
تمكنت من حسابي وتقدير مدى بعد مطلق النار
وفقا لحساباتي فقد كان مطلق النار على بعد
ما بين
180 مترا
الى 200 متر
واكتشفنا ايضا ان هناك مجموعه من جنود جيش
الدفاع الاسرائيلي كانوا على بعد 200 متر
من ذلك التقاطع
حيث كانت الصحفيه والمصور
فان بصمه الصوت تتطابق مع المسافه وتلك
الرصاصات كانت تتجه نحو الصحفيه
اعتقد جازما ان ذلك يدعم حقيقه مفادها ان
اطلاق النار جاء من جنود الجيش الاسرائيلي
[موسيقى]
دسوق الحظ يبدو ان الجيش الاسرائيلي بمثل
تلك المواقف يشعر انه يمكنه الافلات من اي
شيء
[موسيقى]